okay willkommen zur heutigen Session
ähm
in der letzten Session
ähm hier ist der Link zur letzten Session
auf youtube wir haben ähm alan turings
Vorstellung von künstlicher Intelligenz diskutiert
die Frage ob es
intelligente Maschinen sind
und in der heutigen Session werden wir
erstmal eine kurze
[Musik  ]
kurze Diskussion seiner kurzen Zusammenfassung
seiner
Theorie
während der Theorie, und dann werden wir
zur
Position der heutigen Sitzung
übergehen, nämlich um John Cerl
und sein sehr berühmtes Kapitel über
Computerdenken in seinem
Buch Minds Brains and Science von 1984,
und ich denke, Sie ehren das  wollte
etwas über die beziehung
zwischen touring und searle und auch john
von neumann sagen,
also übergebe ich dir
okay hallo auch von meiner seite schön dich wieder zu sehen
ähm ich möchte nicht
zu viele dinge über
jon soils sogenannten sagen  Chinesisches Zimmerargument
und seine Beziehung zum
Turing-Argument in Bezug auf
das Nachahmungsspiel oder wie es später
als Turing-Test bezeichnet wird,
denn das ist es, was wir w  Ich mache heute
und gemeinsam darüber
nachzudenken und zu diskutieren, in welcher Weise
diese beiden Texte zueinander in Beziehung stehen
, deshalb habe ich eine Art Site-
Anmerkung vorbereitet, um einen kleinen Einblick in die
Hintergründe dessen
zu geben, was wir heute tun,
weil es irgendwie interessant ist,
dass  auf der einen seite, wenn man diese
beiden texte so liest, wie wir es
eine woche nach der anderen in einem seminar direkt konfrontieren,
scheint es völlig klar zu sein, dass diese beiden
texte
in direktem zusammenhang stehen,
aber gleichzeitig scheint es so  um
offensichtlich zu sein
,
dass sich searle
nicht auf turing bezieht,
erwähnt er den namen nicht
im ganzen buch
und
gleichzeitig
scheint ein schwerpunkt des textes von searle
etwas seltsam zu sein, wenn man
direkt an den text von touring denkt
Was ich meine, ist oder worauf ich
anspielen möchte, ist
die Analogie von Geist und Gehirn von oder nicht
Geist und Gehirn, Gehirn und Computer
des gehirns das menschliche gehirn in erster linie und
der digitale computer
er greift diese art von analogie direkt an,
aber soweit ich das sehe, ist es überhaupt kein
fokus von ähm,
diese art von analogie zu behandeln, es ist eher
möglich zu argumentieren, dass diese art von
analogie  widerspricht ein bisschen
turings text, obwohl
es gleichzeitig ziemlich klar zu sein scheint, dass die
seele turing auch kritisiert,
also ist die beziehung zwischen diesen beiden
texten etwas komplizierter als wenn
zwei männer direkt miteinander diskutieren
und ich denke a  Der Grund dafür ist
ja, dass etwas
passiert ist. Nehmen wir an,
der Text von Um Alan Turing stammt aus dem Jahr 1950
, über den wir letzte Woche gesprochen haben,
und John Searles Text stammt aus den 80ern,
also liegen 30 Jahre dazwischen,
und Turing ist mit Sicherheit immer noch sehr
wichtig für AI  forschung ähm in der
zwischenzeit
aber ist eine menge dinge
in diesem sich
entwickelnden forschungsfeld passiert
und ich denke, einer der punkte
, die sich nach turings texten entwickelt haben, ist
diese analogie
von  Gehirn
und Computer,
in denen in gewisser Weise das Argument von Current
und Hörtests wieder auftauchen
und eine Rolle spielen, ist immer noch
irrelevant und wichtig für diese ganze
Diskussion, aber der Rahmen hat
sich ein wenig geändert, und
deshalb wollte ich einen anderen
Typen vorstellen  und sehr wichtig für
die entwicklung von computern die
entwicklung der informatik und die
entwicklung der iai-forschung und dieser typ
ist john f neumann
john von neumann alle auch sehr
jung
gestorben 1957
aber ein jahr nach seinem tod erschien ein aufsatz
im
herausgegeben von
seine
frau clara von neumann
und dieser
aufsatz ist nicht wirklich fertig
er
ist aus dem manuskript heraus in gewisser weise
ein unfertiges manuskript herausgegeben und in diesem
1958 erschienenen
buch steht genau das im fokus, inwiefern wir
den computer dem digitalen
computer analog vergleichen können  computer und das menschliche
gehirn
so im fokus steht hier der vergleich
die analogie bzw. der direkte vergleich
zwischen computer und dem br
Was von Neumann in diesem Buch also tut, ist, dass
er zuerst Computer,
analoge Computer und digitale Computer beschreibt,
dann diskutiert er das Gehirn, soweit er es
versteht, ist er kein Experte
auf diesem Gebiet, aber er weiß viele Dinge
darüber
und versucht, es näher auszuführen  Eine recht
differenzierte und nuancierte Art und Weise,
wie wir
das Gehirn
mit dem Computer vergleichen können,
und ein
Argument, das in diesem Text enthalten ist, habe ich den
Eindruck,
dass er versucht zu argumentieren
, dass mit Sicherheit die Hardware oder die nasse
Abnutzung des Gehirns und der  Computer, ob
analog
oder digital,
das ist ziemlich unterschiedlich,
aber er versucht, so etwas wie eine
Konvergenz des Computers und des
Gehirns in Bezug auf die
Funktionalität dieser beiden Maschinen zu fokussieren,
also scheint er so etwas wie das zu sehen,
was das Gehirn
zumindest sein kann  ungefähr
ungefähr von einem digitalen Computer berechnet wird
und was ein Computer
von einem menschlichen Gehirn
so und in diesem Zusammenhang zumindest ungefähr berechnen oder verarbeiten kann
insbesondere die turing-maschine erscheint,
so dass
die turing-maschine und viele
verschiedene teile des gehörs jetzt
von dieser art der analogie
zwischen computer und gehirn und der
frage eingerahmt werden, auf welche weise ihre funktionalität
verglichen werden kann
oder auf welche weise ihre funktionalität sich
beiden annähert  andere oder in gewisser
Weise konvergieren,
und ich denke,
dies ist nur ein indikator
für eine art gedanken für eine art
forschungsprogramm
, das sich
möglicherweise nach turing entwickelt hat und nicht wirklich in
kohärenz mit turings plänen oder
absichten steht
und
das von
jon soul sehr kritisch angegangen wird  also müssen wir
uns bewusst sein,
wenn wir heute turing während des
nachahmungsspiels oder den turing-test und ähm
und das argument von of
of tron surl in Bezug auf das chinesische Zimme
vergleichen, müssen wir u
s bewusst sein, dass eine Menge
Dinge um und in uns passi
ren  dazwischen, aber ich finde es trotzdem
total sinnvoll, das zu tun, was wir
heute vorhaben, also war das ein bisschen
meine historische Randbemerkung
, zu der ich übergegangen bin  new york
vielen dank arno für deine einführung
überblick ich werde jetzt
wie immer mit unseren schlüsselfragen fortfahren
ähm ich werde sie einfach lesen
also erstens wie verhält
sich der suchaccount von ai zum touring arno hat
schon etwas über diese
beziehung gesagt was wirklich interessant ist
dann zweitens  was bedeutet cer mit starker
ai sie alle kennen diese begriffe starke und
schwache ai künstliche intelligenz und
es gibt ein vorkommen von starker ai in
kreisen text der unserer meinung nach
wirklich interessant ist
die dritte frage ist mit welchen
argumenten argumentiert sir dagegen
Identifizierung von mentalen Prozessen und
Programmprozessen
vierte Frage wie funktioniert Searles
chinesisches Zimmerargument
fünfte Frage warum können digitale
Computer nicht so semantische Inhalte erzeugen und mit Bedeutung umgehen
sechste Frage, die mit der
fünften Frage verwandt ist warum ist ein digitaler Computer
entsprechend  Zelle kann nur simulieren,
aber mental nicht duplizieren,
also sind dies die sechs Fragen
an  d Wie
bereits in unserer letzten E-Mail geschrieben,
möchten wir nun kleine Gruppen bilden
und diese sechs
Fragen zuerst intern diskutieren und dann,
nach sagen wir 15 Minuten, werden wir uns
virtuell versammeln und diese Fragen gemeinsam diskutieren